welches sind die vielversprechendsten
medikamente gegen kuwait 19 jedenfalls
würde sicher nicht desinfektionsmittel
seien das gespritzt wird wie der
amerikanische präsident donald trump
vorschlägt forschungsteams weltweit
arbeiten mit hochdruck an arzneimitteln
um die korona pandemie medikamentös
einzudämmen doch bisher gibt es weder
eine wirksame sichere zugelassene
therapie noch impfstoffe hier ist der
überblick über die spannendsten
kandidaten für die therapie von corona
klicks um science-fiction ist täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen sagte niemals nie aber die
meisten fachleute halten es für
unwahrscheinlich dass noch in diesem
jahr 2020 massenimpfung verfügbar sein
werden auch wenn die entwicklung von
impfstoffen gegen das neue corona virus
saß kopf zwei derzeit sehr schnell
vorangeht doch die hoffnung liegen
derzeit eher darauf medikamente zu
finden mit denen bereits infizierte
behandelt werden könnten
diese könnten dafür sorgen dass coop 19
schnell abklingt und nicht
lebensbedrohend ist natürlich werden
bereits jetzt patientinnen und patienten
klar mit schweren verläufen in der
klinik behandelt doch nicht mit einer
bestimmten wirksame therapie gegen die
infektion mit dem neuartigen erreger saß
koch 2 die medizinische versorgung
besteht vor allem darin die symptome zu
behandeln es geht ums fieber senken
ausreichend flüssigkeit schmerzmittel
und die unterstützung der atmung noch
sind dem medizinischen personal also
weitgehend die hände gebunden es sei
denn sie probieren es mit einer noch
nicht zugelassenen oder experimentellen
therapie tatsächlich konzentrieren sich
viele forschungen auf medikamente die
bereits gegen eine andere krankheit
zugelassen sind oder sich zumindest
bereits in der entwicklung befinden die
medikamente müssen eben nur
umfunktioniert werden doch welche eignen
sich um bei der aktuellen corona
erkrankung zu helfen hier kann man drei
gruppen unterscheiden zum einen die
sogenannten antiviralen medikamente die
verhindern dass sich die viren vermehren
und in die lungenzellen 1 bei
ursprünglich wurden solche antiviralen
medikamente gegen hepatitis c gruppe
sass hiv und ebola entwickelt jemand
klicks um science-fiction hatten wir ja
bereits über den wirkstoff rem der see
wir berichtet ein antivirus medikament
das unter anderem
ebola infektionen eingesetzt inzwischen
wird er nach angaben des us unternehmens
gilead sciences bei 1000 betroffene in
asiatischen und anderen ländern getestet
allerdings spricht das ergebnis einer
studie aus china gegen das medikament
zusammengefasst war es einfach
wirkungslos zu möglichen kandidaten
zählt beispielsweise aber auch der
antikörper wirkstoff lehrer niemand der
bereits in studien gegen hiv erprobt
wird bezüglich seiner wirkung bei der
erkrankung coop 19 hat das
pharmaunternehmen zo sin jetzt eine
phase 2 studie beantragt dabei wird
festgestellt ob das arzneimittel
positive auswirkung auf diese spezielle
atemwegserkrankung hat meistens nimmt
eine kleine anzahl an patientinnen und
patienten teil in frankreich setzt der
pharmakonzern sanofi auf ein malaria
medikament zur behandlung der korona
infizierten die aktien platini habe sich
in ersten studien als zitat
vielversprechend gezeigt der konzern
bietet der regierung in frankreich
deswegen mehrere millionen dosen der
arznei
damit könnten bis zu 300.000 infizierte
behandelt werden doch ein
wissenschaftlicher beweis dass dieses
malariamittel gegen das corona virus
wirkt steht noch aus und deswegen will
die französische regierung erstmal die
entsprechenden test zunächst auf eine
größere anzahl von patientinnen und
patienten aushalten eine weitere gruppe
der bereits existierende medikamente die
nur noch umfunktioniert werden müssen
besteht aus den sogenannten
immunmodulatoren diese wurden gegen
entzündliche darmerkrankung und gegen
rheumatoide arthritis entwickelt und
begrenzen die abwehrreaktion des körpers
so wird verhindert dass dadurch noch
mehr schaden angerichtet wird als durch
die viren selbst klar ist hierbei aber
auch dass immunreaktion an sich wichtig
und richtig sehen sie dürfen nur nicht
überhand nehmen sodass mehr schaden in
der lunge entsteht als dass sie helfen
so wird beispielsweise der
immunmodulator sarin nomad in einer
studie mit komik 19 betroffenen getestet
der ursprünglich für die rheuma therapie
zugelassen ist die dritte gruppe besteht
aus medikamenten für lungenkranke sie
sollen dafür sorgen dass die lunge der
patientinnen und patienten das blut
weiterhin genügend mit sauerstoff
versorgen kann mit am start ein
medikament mit dem wirkstoff vier fini
drohnen das schon zugelassen ist um eine
bestimmte lungenfibrose zu behandeln
es sorgt dafür dass sich geschehen
das lungengewebe nicht vernarbt
forschungsteams in china führen tests
mit diesem wirkstoff durch da es
möglicherweise auch coop 19 betroffenen
helfen könnte natürlich gibt es aber
auch fachleute die sich auf die neue
entwicklung von medikamenten
konzentrieren doch bei der entwicklung
von arzneimitteln gibt es hohe
sicherheitsstandards und die müssen
eingehalten werden laut der
bundesforschungsministerin anja
karliczek würden die verfahren in der
aktuellen situation aber beschleunigt so
weit man es eben verantworten kann doch
es sind wichtige schritte die ein
medikament durchlaufen muss es auf dem
markt kommt es wird nicht nur in
zellkulturen sondern auch im tierversuch
getestet dann erst folgt die klinische
prüfung an dutzenden und besser sogar
noch 100 patientinnen und patienten und
das ist wirklich unerlässlich denn
achtung mehr als 90 prozent der neu
entwickelten medikamente fallen in der
klinischen phase durch manchmal sind die
nebenwirkungen schlimmer als die
positive wirkung gegen eine krankheit
somit ist diese also entscheidend neben
der intensiven analyse bereits
bestehende medikamente und der
neuentwicklung von arzneimitteln wird
auch an der entwicklung möglicher
impfstoffe gearbeitet nach angaben der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who sind
dazu bereits 41 projekte angelaufen wer
ist christian drosten warum ihm die
politiker bei corona vertrauen
lebenslauf karriere aktuelles neues
video by dr wissenschaft cooler neuer
kanal bei unserer wissenschafts
initiative auf youtube es 1054 unbedingt
anklicken anschauen das video wirklich
hammer und unbedingt dr wissenschaft
abonnieren bis dann da dran